خدوها هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيون وسط
الدخان هو تمويهم عسكري لانقاذ زملائهم
الجرحى هي فكره هذا التدريب شمال اوكرانيا
اليوم لا قتال هذه الوحده لا تريد استفزاز
جيرانها خلال فتره الاعياد
الاخر
منذ نهايه اكتوبر
الاوكرانيه لمواجهه حتى شهر مارس كان عدد
الاوكرانيين المدربين على القتال قليلا
عند هذه الحدود لكننا مواطنين كذبتنا
انضموا للقتال
خبره عسكريه كنا جميعا مدنيين ولم نحمل
سلاحا من قبل تغيرت الامور بشكل جذري
تتحضر الوحده للبقاء عند الحدود طيله فصل
الشتاء بمرور الوقت اصبح كالعائله لكن
اسرتك كل منهم تنتظره بفارغ الصبر في
المنزل لم يرى بعضهم احبائهم منذ عده اشهر
نتحدث فقط الى عائلتنا
مع اقتراب الذكرى الاولى للحرب
انا متاكد انه في الرابع
[موسيقى]